an amazing quick fig jam crostini with
creamy burrata and a hearty main pub
beef cheek ragout with pappardelle 50s
just think the size your little cheeks
yeah
imagine size of a cow were there and the
cheek is right underneath here yeah mmm
you give them a really nice season with
salt pepper on their place so beef
cheeks very cheap my cut that takes sort
of a long time to cook yeah but give it
a bit of love let it cook in the oven it
comes out like a dream I don't touch of
all in the pan what we want to do is get
them really nicely colors should sit
into the pan sits another top of the
know what the onion chunky for like
three three and half hours so you go
down down down and then again there and
there so it doesn't overcook so a really
good color on the cheeks lime ass so how
do you leave that a restaurants if they
take so long they go in the oven
literally half hour 6/7 up in the
morning sweetheart for hours and ready
for lunch and the longer you leave them
in their juices and the cooking liquor
the better you guys close the garlic
onions in and garlic in please
nice where's your baby there's onions
and that garlic really nicely colors put
the cheeks back in please right red wine
in okay the red wine is gonna be glazed
the pan so deglaze will basically sort
of rinse all that flavor of the bottom
of the pan okay cuz that's gonna make
the most amazing sauce now you could use
tomato puree but chopped canned tomatoes
you'll make a much better sauce and top
that with some stock so the secret of
braising is having little of the meat
exposed and 90% of its submerged see
them
they're like little crocodile heads
popping up out of the water turn the gas
off and leave the Liz
chest off at the end there if we had to
cover it completely the steam hits the
top yeah this water comes right back oh
yeah solar still
that's right in the oven 140 150 for
about three and a half to four hours
we're gonna now do a fig and burrata
crostini oh okay let's take the figs
we're gonna make a nice slightly spicy
fig jam
take all the tops yep in half and each
half into sweet sugar the touch of salt
in there okay we're making a jam but we
don't want to be too sweet and then
these little babies
what's the shape stars star nice it's
Tommy's take them from the and a seat
plums when you're driving like that
so intensifies the flavor really
important to count how many put in there
okay so one two three four five so
they're just a fruit flavor let me take
so that's right
secret here let's get that camera going
so when I hear of jam I don't think of
caramel no but this is a very fast jam
caramel starting to color autumn very
carefully drop the figs in there good so
the juice out the figs is starting to
break down the camera yeah what that is
I'll sweep a little of that on my
challenge well that sort of sweet and
sour flavor leave that cooking for three
or four minutes now let's slice after
pattern in Italian crostini means little
bits of toast but it can be made out of
leftover baguette sourdough or any
crusty open textured bread we're stayin
authentically Italian with ciabatta
season them and then drizzle little
touch of olive oil on their both sides
really important because we're gonna
grill the breast
push it down what's a love take it off
with the Chiappetta toasted we need to
carefully extract the star in these pods
from our piping hot fig jam my Jack we
got one little bugger two five oh no
this is right now we've got the green
light to crush skins disintegrated all
Jack carefully spreads the crostini with
our hot fig jam I couldn't fail the last
element to our starter the creamy
Italian speciality burrata a lot of
money bags you can get alicia's this
looks fun doesn't it
we need to season them lightly drizzle
over a little olive oil and dust them
with lemon zest imagine that sat there
and you Tess all that often you stick on
top of that mmm back to the main course
to match our hearty beef cheeks I've
chosen to use pappardelle rule number
one when cooking pasta salt in first
something first good olive all in pasta
in
twist it round so you don't break it
bring that back up the boys gonna take
back three or four minutes flat leaf
parsley scratch it up for me
yep I'm chopping now wait to see these
beef cheeks beauties they're very soft
want to taste mmm so good John you've
just dribbled on your jumper Joe really
right drain the pasta salt pepper pasta
little drizzle of olive oil
wait to put your fresh pastas nicely
chopped nicely chopped in this is the
magic bit okay you take a little ladle
of the juice for that at the bottom and
you put pasta on top of that sauce
honestly oh my gosh your sisters are
gonna love you even more now you know
what about when you cook this for your
girlfriend one day anyway you got the
recipe from will you promise promise
I know what you're stealing daddy's
thunder one YouTube jaw on their two
beautiful jaws on there and then the
bird jaw and then you go over in the
sauce how cool is that
delicious you've got new burrata I've
got the cheese let's go baby
don't be cheeky